kollegen ist es gelungen exklusiv mit
einer frau zu sprechen von dessen
kindern christian b der mutmaßlichen
täter im fall der kleinen maddie
onaniert haben soll am 11 juni 2017 gab
es eine feier in sauber tolomeo dem
esstisch an diesem platz
es gab musik stände mit essen und
trinken
es waren bestimmt 1000 menschen verteilt
in diesem park kinder spielten an diesem
spielplatz hinter mir auch mein kind
spielte hier mit anderen kindern
ich saß dort am tisch als meine tochter
zu mir gelaufen kam um zu warnen dass
ein mann am spielplatz ist der seine
hose heruntergelassen hat und seinen
penis gezeigt hat mama er hat sein team
angezeigt hat sie gesagt ich stand
sofort auf und lief raus um zu schauen
was dort passiert ich sah dass andere
männer die auch hier am platz waren ihn
schon gepackt hatten
sie hielten ihn fest bis die polizei
ankam alle kinder wurden dann vom
spielplatz gebracht die portugiesische
polizei konnte ihn identifizieren und
stellte fest dass interpol ihn sucht
deshalb wurde der mann erst mal nach
portimao zur polizei gebracht und von
dort aus wurde er nach deutschland
überliefert mehr information hatten wir
zu diesem zeitpunkt nicht neulich im
fernsehen habe ich christian b gesehen
ich habe sein gesicht erkannt
ich dachte ich habe ihn schon mal
irgendwo gesehen den größten schock habe
ich jetzt erlebt nicht damals
damals wussten wir nicht wer der mann
war wir dachten dass er vielleicht zu
viel getrunken hat ich konnte mir nicht
vorstellen dass hier jemand gefährlich
werden könnte
dass ein mann im park sein könnte und
dass er so nah an meiner tochter war
dass er sie angefasst und vielleicht
mitgenommen hätte nachdem wir ihn im
fernsehen gesehen und erfahren haben
dass christian wie viele kriminelle
taten begangen hat und in vielen fällen
des kindesmissbrauchs verdächtigt wird
erst dann wurde es richtig schwer für
mich
da habe ich wirklich angst gespürt
dieser gefährliche mann war so nah an
meiner tochter
er hat mit ihr gesprochen
ja ich denke schon dass er was mit dem
fall maddie zu tun haben könnte